his show the lead with Jake Tapper can
be seen every single day at 4:00 Eastern
Time on CNN and he is right here on the
Rich Eisen show here in Washington DC
good to see you jack it's great to see
you it's I guess I saw you a few weeks
ago at the big slick at the big slick
you know last time you were on this show
you were you were guesting if you will
with Will Forte yeah and then mere hours
later behind the set on the actual field
yeah you you you pulled like a bud
Harrelson Pete Rose type brawl rolling
around on the ground that with Will
Forte what what what happened one of the
biggest mistakes of my life well the
year before we had done a I was covering
third base and he was on third base and
I tried to shove him off the bag and
turned into a fake brawl and everybody
joined in and this year I tried to get a
brawl going it had been tagged out at
second and then he stayed he kept
running and then he was on third and I
checked it to it and I ran over to him
to try to tackle him forgetting that I
was 49 years old as opposed to 18
mm-hm and I think I bruised a rib you
came up do you came up your knee was
bleeding that was the least of it the
next month for the next month anytime I
coughed or sneezed it was jusqu is it
pain Wow are you serious yes it's your
oblique you had an oblique exquisite
pain my sternum it wasn't broken but it
was bruised and I thought boy that was
really dumb
entirely my fault and also by the way I
guess Forte who's not a big man he's not
big he's not like a Will Ferrell type
character he's he's dirty he's like an
oak I mean that hurt so he's he's he's
more compact than you would think much
stronger than and much younger than I am
I guess so are you admitting you're
better at fake brawl than real bro yeah
Wow
I admit that I would that that was a
horrible thing for me to now when did
you realize that immediately is that
right and immediately I was like oh my
god it was funny because years ago
here's a similar story years ago the pro
ball was 2006 okay so I'm in Hawaii
doing the end of an NFL Total Access
with Ray Lewis yeah and Rod Woodson and
they were teaching me they're like we
had like two minutes to go and they're
like we're alive and they're like how
would you like to hit a tackling dummy
to close the show and I'm like okay how
hard could that be exactly how hard
could that be
and I thought to myself also Ray Lewis
and Rod Woodson teaching me how to hit a
tackling dummy if this was if this was
put up for a charity auction yeah people
would bid an absurd amount of money for
the right to do this Who am I to say no
I will not try it's a dummy it's gonna
be like hitting a you know like a
balloon is this big old bag right like a
mood
letting a Shamu exactly hitting a shmoo
I didn't thought about that at the time
but that's why I'm glad that you're here
now to help provide that sort of
perspective so but Rod Woodson held the
bag and Ray was teaching me how to hit
it you gotta get it you know bend your
bend at the hips and go up hit it with
your chest okay i'ma do it yeah let's do
it
Rod Woodson holding the bag much like
Lucy holding the football for Charlie
Brown as I was hitting the bag let it go
and I went straight through it my my
microphone pack on the back of my belt
goes flying just to add to the physical
comedy to this whole thing and I got up
and just decided to just you know fly
like a bird or whatever like a raven
even though I had no idea was doing the
Eagles thing at the time and end of show
we're all laughing cut to about a half
an hour later and my right arm is in
such searing pain my shoulder searing
pain I landed on my AC joint and I
couldn't move my arm for the rest of the
trip yeah like an idiot it gives you
insight into what these guys go through
and why they so many of them use
medicine to help them out yeah I did
what we had we called the trainer up on
the show the next day on live TV and I
had it I would go to my left hand for
the microphone for the rest of the week
is that true that's true stop
I to go to my left hand for the
microphone for the rest of the week you
know I couldn't lift my arm it's good to
see you man I appreciate you being here
I mean you're just in hell I'm jet lag
you are I'm jet like we I just got off
the flight from Helsinki yesterday and
then drove to the studio did my show yes
and which I watched yesterday yeah now
here you are there go quite a I mean
quite a quite a new cycle yes it has
been quite some time just being around
in this town too has just been
interesting to say the least I think
it's I mean every day of this presidency
is unprecedented and new but I mean it's
the first time I've ever seen an
American president side with an enemy
over American people hmm I mean the
United States was attacked and there he
was with the guy who led the cyber
attack and you know saying that
suggesting that he believes him and not
our own law enforcement intelligence I
was reading about on the flight back at
one point apparently Trump was watching
the home run derby yeah I read that I
read that he's out there watching maybe
your guy Reese Hoskins go go yard it
looks pretty good you know and here we
are at the edge doing well I mean here
we are at the all-star break and your
Philadelphia Phillies first place in the
NL East a half game and front half game
yeah but the brakes are always good they
are yeah what in what you know in this
town are people talking about Bryce
Harper's struggles at all yeah the fact
that he might be moving people in
Washington are very Nats focused there's
a real love and obsession for the Nats
and in fact we not when they started I
there was a moment when a lot of my
friends from college thought that I
should embrace the Nats and just like
get there on the ground floor and just
you know so I would know everything
because when in somebody's life you have
an opportunity to like be with a team
from day one mm-hmm you know but know
I'm a Phillies fan right of course and
now also being here I imagine I don't
know what your travels were when the
Capitals what at all and okay rocky are
you serious I really just knew the
Flyers never know even when the Broad
Street Bullies were in their heyday it's
just and all my friends love them I just
I don't like it and I have to say I
tried to watch the playoffs this year
yes having not watch
Hokkien literally in years and there was
the last time I watched they made it
easier for you you couldn't follow the
puck they had something in the puck
glowing the club that's been awhile I
liked it I liked I liked it I could see
the puck now I spend the whole time
trying to watch hockey I'm like where'd
the puck go
what by the way where's the puck by the
way I don't they bring back the goal you
were you were in this because you Mikey
you might have been the only person who
like see the puck now I spend the whole
time trying to figure out the game
where's the puck I don't feel like I'm
always like 5 seconds behind the action
anyway I don't like right well maybe we
could start right here bring back the
glowing puck just I I don't mean to tell
you how to do your job this is by the
way not much maybe that's the lead
whatever you run down looks like sounds
like you're saying that when it comes to
the Glo better better odds of getting
the gorgeous ladies of wrestling yes
nope we're workshopping this right now
we need glow in the HL together I would
go with hey before we take our first
break the Hellfire Club congratulations
thank you so much let me tell you
something
I don't know how that I told you this
when I was I think riding on the bus
with you a big slick to one of the many
events well we're a couple gin gin and
tonics into the day a little bit how the
hell do you have time to do some this
was fun to write and I'd been working on
it for several years but it was fun to
write I mean just taking a break from
nonfiction and going right into fiction
and making it all up and read it I love
history and reading about history and if
I write a sequel I think of the Year boy
Sinatra is gonna be in the sequel
fantast yeah yeah if I write one no how
do you not write one I mean what have
you talked to the publisher and get a
deal and all that stuff well I
understand that but I mean this thing is
because I know you're a huge Sinatra fan
yes and anybody who's gone karaoking
with rich knows that perhaps he's too
much of a Frank Sinatra fan to the
exclusion of any other any other
recording two artists well I mean other
than looking-glass cuz I sing brandy
you're a fine girl a fine song yeah what
a good wife yeah right but you're but
yes Sinatra always comes out when you're
around yes but there was a time in 1962
this if I if I write a sequel it would
be about this would be part of it there
was a time in 1962 when JFK was gonna
come out to California President Kennedy
was gonna come up to California to he
was he was going to be speaking at uh I
think at Berkeley and Sinatra wanted him
to stay at the at the Sinatra I think a
Palm Beach estate mm-hmm and he had all
the stuff built he had a helipad built
in extra rooms and the press corps would
stay here and this you know all this all
this stuff because he and Jack were
buddies and Bobby Kennedy the Attorney
General squashed it because of Sinatra's
mob ties and Sinatra lost it and he
excommunicated
Peter Lawford who was a Kennedy
brother-in-law hmm from the Rat Pack and
there's a rumor that he took a
sledgehammer to the helipad he just went
nuts I just love that story oh my god
yeah that's true sledge fiction that's
real edge hammer to the helipad yeah but
Peter Lawford would be the avatar Peter
Lawford with like one drop instead of
garbage across Sacred Lands it would be
just the trashed Sinatra comp this
sledgehammer to the helipad knee
fantastic I want to take a 60-second
break and come back and get into this
thing okay this thing is the die-hard
Christmas oh yeah you were the die-hard
Christmas truther I wouldn't call it
that but I I will because Bruce Willis
is uh is on my side and that is John
McClane sir we the skin puppet that read
the script that was written by Steve
D'Souza the screenwriter who is on my
side of the debate we are back in 60
seconds with this and and we have also
called your IMDB page and you
Wikipedia page with certain items and we
want to know if it's real news or fake
okay fair enough with Jake Tapper of CNN
when we come back at 6:00
you're listening to the Rich Eisen show
okay we're back here in Washington DC
Chris Haines of ESPN is gonna join us on
the latest in the Kawhi Leonard trade
that is rumored to be going down between
the Spurs and Toronto Raptors and Ken
Rosenthal will be joining us in our
three about the rumor trade that's about
to be going down between the Orioles and
Dodgers about Manny Machado but for the
moment we have Jake Tapper of CNN check
out the lead with Jake Tapper later on
today at 4:00 Eastern Time and every
single day and then of course State of
the Union with Jake which is must-see
viewing at 9:00 a.m. Eastern Time and
noon Eastern Time every single Sunday on
CNN and then the Hellfire Club which is
a great book a great novel that jake has
has put out there that hopefully will
have if you have the time and the
dealing combination they follow up
certainly if it's gonna involve a a
Frank Sinatra trashing a helipad story
that'll be fantastic that's a sequel now
let's get into this you not your family
denies that okay fairness
I appreciate you well we don't want what
Tina Sinatra all up so no that's right
that I heard about that
yeah also this week you know while you
were in Helsinki yeah it was the 30th
anniversary of the release of the
Christmas classic die hard hmm which has
been as has been noted some blossom
matter when you release a film whether
exactly Miracle on 34th Street one of
the all-time classics released in May
yeah and it was it was fun to have the
week crescendoed with the taping of the
roast of Bruce Willis has it haven't
seen it yet yes and that's out later on
this month but it was leaked out that
his final remark of the night of a roast
where every quality joke comes from a
germ of truth is that diehard is not a
Christmas movie that was his walk off
thank you good night thanks for being on
which I felt was aimed at me personally
by the way I felt like there was a I
don't know if he knew it
but it was aimed at you person well I
think I am one of the most prominent
assert of the fact of the diamond a
Serdar as a service order of the fact
that runs with that rhymes with truth
are in a way okay under of facts movie
ever made there's a tweet of mine yes
well done okay no but you understand
wrote an entire poem about oh I saw die
hard being a Christmas was aimed me it
was a response to you yeah but i--but
right but I tweeted it for everyone but
so let me just now that we wanted to
build the case I mean you want me to
explain why no no human element we were
here first while I was doing it for why
John McClane and his pursuit of his wife
Holly why that story has something to do
with Christmas I mean is that what you
want me to do it it's sure because to me
a Christmas movie isn't a Christmas
movie just because it takes place during
Christmas there must be something that
no no the definition of his Christmas
movie is yes it may take place during
Christmas but there is some essence of
the Christmas spirit redemption is woven
throughout the entire saving the world
um like redemption no like going after
large illness no this is evil miracle a
miracle do you not think that John
McClane's performance and success was a
miraculous no I don't know no one man
against this this group of thugs how
many movies do you see one man against
it because it just happens to take place
during Christmas that makes it a
Christmas you don't think that John
McClane in any way was intended to be a
Christ figure symbolically absolutely
not just big mata on his feet mean
nothing to you nothing he's not wearing
a shirt his bleeding shoes are taken off
he had a t took off his shoes that's why
they shot the glass there is no ever
shot the glass in the Bible I mean like
what are we talking about here I don't
think they had glass so Christmas movies
have to only have like be limited by
what is experienced in the Year Zero
people have to have some feel-good thing
at the end like it's a wonderful life me
and rich we talked about it says swings
which angel goddess wastes John McClane
Reginald veljohnson wings John McClane
it was a Redemption what's wings a nice
flight home with the teddy bear and the
first life all right
please John McClane comes to on
Christmas Eve comes to try to fix his
life right with his wife Holly her name
is her name is Holly like deck the halls
with boughs of is her name Molly no her
name is not Molly no her name is holly
okay all right
the entire film takes place on Christmas
Eve start to finish it's not just like
one scene the entire film Christmas
references throughout the movie
everything songs references questions
about you know do the I D do they even
have Christmas in Japan mister Nakatomi
today you know that it's throughout
there is a Judas character right I mean
there is a pregnant woman at Nakatomi
Plaza there are there is reference after
reference of miracles and one man
sacrificing himself to the point that he
has stigmata bloody feats that just
happens you're like oh they shot out the
window
yes why do you think the screenwriter
had them shoot out the window so that he
could have bloody feet do you think this
movie could have taken place on st.
Patrick's Day yeah can't take place on
st. Patrick's Day because there's no
people don't travel from one century I
think the movie could have taken place
on New Year's Eve of course it could
have been absolutely I agree you could
have taken place in any single time that
people travel from one part of the
country yeah it'll be what I didn't it
took place on Christmas Eve what so so
is Argyll an apostle I mean like I mean
at what point is your analogy start
losing its steam he saves he saved the
day
Argyll I don't know I just didn't say
he's wise man I just didn't think that
you know I I don't see any shootouts
involving terrorists in the miracle on
34th Street a Christmas story the only
the only the only heaven is is the
Renault
you can't having a BB gun there's no
action film that can be a Christmas with
me is that is that the idea I mean is
that your argument your fundamental
argument is if it's an action movie it's
not a Christmas movie is that is that
the argument I guess so yeah that's an
argument that's weak that's kind of weak
I mean I want to get into reindeer games
to Monica laughs let the man's like
Monica Potter you already called Bruce
Willis a skin pop I mean I want to say
something about that I have been a fan
of Bruce Willis since the Seagrams wine
cooler commercial okay Wow way back in
the dead steep I watched every episode
of moonlighting enjoyed them all even
the one that was based on the Billy Joel
album the bridge I don't know if your
member big man on Mulberry Street keep
us deep I'm a fan of his so I don't mean
to berate him but I do think a
screenwriter knows more about the intent
of a film than the actor I do think that
so Bruce Willis saying this joke to end
the road it was it was funny and I think
it was yes Sarah's joke which is which
is which is it was an amusing joke and
buzzy it was also buzzy right it was
intended to create buzz so people watch
it exactly I don't think he actually
knew what he was saying necessarily
maybe he did Jake Tapper everybody i'm
sanna Bruce I don't want to take away
from mr. Willis this debate is over you
guys just got owned by Jake I did not
get know if her name was Holly Claus
maybe but Holly I might have I might
have lost to a party we've lost edges
might have lost to a die-hard puppet I
don't know what that I'm not a puppet
you're the puppet you're the puppet I'm
thinking of Helsinki all right do we
have the drop the the celebrity true or
false drop here on the Rich Eisen show
that we'll play with Jake Tapper go for
it let's hit it please celebrity
true or false oh great drop it celebrity
true or false it's a great drop right
there okay Jake Tapper we have called
your IMDB and Wikipedia pages I just say
one thing about all of this yes sir
which is there's a great Dennis Miller
joke from the
off-white album in the eighties where he
talks about how he doesn't trust train
travel because he doesn't like any form
of travel where the general public has
access to the brakes mm-hmm and he
doesn't want to get into the accent
because Gus thinks he saw a woodchuck
that's kind of like my vibe when it
comes to information on the Internet but
there's no a Webster he didn't outsource
it to just like okay just everybody fill
in the blank on the dictionary we're
just gonna like have fun we have fun
general Palmer giving you the plants
that said real news or fake news
involving a Jake Tapper great okay first
one as a child you attended the summer
camp Rama and the Poconos that is true I
did I did attend Ramon the Poconos in
Lake Como Pennsylvania a Clio yeah
there's a lake como Pennsylvania look at
all like Lake Como in Italy I could tell
last time I was throwing back cos amigas
with mister with Clooney with mr.
Clooney and Amol at his Kate Lake Como
man state yes I have to say that it
didn't remind me of my Jewish camp in
the Pocono Mountains nor did it remind
me of the canoes okay very good there
was no Jake Tapper real or fake news you
briefly attended the USC School of
Cinematic Arts it's true after I
graduate from Dartmouth in 91 and
everybody was going to law school and I
decided to go to film school and I went
to USC for one semester
did you make a Christmas movie about a
movie about terrorists in any way shape
or form involving a Los Angeles building
I did not okay very good
I did your first on screen credit is for
the role of Spencer on All My Children
is that real news or fake news for Jake
- I did that's a that's interesting I
don't know if it's my first on screen
credit but when the lead launched and it
was in 2013 we did a lot of different
kinds of stories the news cycle was very
different than it is today
all right explore things and we did a
thing about how they were trying to read
to bring back soap operas on the
Internet
and I did play Spencer Spencer Phillips
a TV as part of my I did a story about
them doing this and then they brought me
in
oh so this is sort of like a George
Plimpton paper tiger paper liberal lion
exactly exactly that's what I thought
your you have a writing credit for the
TV movie documentary Leonard Skynyrd's
on Civil War I was the host and reporter
for that on vh1 there was six months of
my life where I worked for it work for
VH on I was trying to learn how to do TV
and that was the very first project it
was a Lynyrd Skynyrd it was an
exploration into what happened with the
band Lynyrd Skynyrd and are you are you
just a die-hard Leonard Skynyrd no no
but it was about how it was about how
the band was feuding and and why they
were and all this other stuff it was you
can find it on YouTube I think you'd
enjoy it did you say the words tied to
the whippin Posen tavern now we focused
a little bit more on Freebird in Sweet
Home Alabama but but I got to meet a
number of the surviving members and at
the very end I went to the crash site
where so Bobo we're all the members of
the band at gentlemen Ronny Minton and
others had died and it was pretty it was
a pretty remarkable your IMDB page
credits an alternate name of Jake
trapper yeah I don't know that that's
fake news is that fake that seems like
fake news out there to know more and
then you you're credited episode 7 as a
disgruntled Eagles fan and the 2002
Dallas Cowboys season of hard knocks
that the real news ruse that was Jake
trapper that might have been Jake
trappers I met at the Super Bowl I met
some of the gang from It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia and and it was it was
lovely and then I found out that they
were filming an episode that takes place
at the Super Bowl and I was upset that I
didn't get to recreate it that was so
that was partly cloudy that was partly
cloudy yeah
great to see you thanks again I know
it's great busy man your jet lag like
crazy the Hellfire Club check it out
where books are sold everywhere and then
CNN would the lead with Jake Tapper the
first lead item today that we have now
found out is going to be about the
return of the glow puck to my demand my
demand
the return of the glee now sometimes I
get a little irate when it comes to
what's going on in the news and the way
fact that I can't see where the puck is
is one of them get out on the puck
that's what we show is everybody able to
see where the puck is are you able to
follow it pretty much State of the Union
with Jake Tapper every single Sunday at
9:00 in Eastern and on a.m. and new and
Eastern great to see you I get to take
the stuff whatever's not nailed down you
make Dave so that's my finger
discounting Jake Tapper you're on the
rink you so much I appreciate the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience